to talk to people about um taking care
of themselves like there's someone who
they have responsibility for and that's
not a political issue too it's it's uh
it's an injunction to
assuming that you have a certain
intrinsic value
you know and that
it's necessary for that value to
manifest itself for you to
push yourself against the world to
challenge yourself because otherwise
what you're capable of won't manifest
itself it has to be developed it has to
be called forth by necessity right you
have to pick a hard problem and try to
solve it and push yourself against it in
order for and you have to try to do that
truthfully and responsibly in order for
what it is that you're
intrinsically
capable of and composed of to come to
the forefront
and that seems like a very positive
thing as far as i'm concerned to
encourage people to be responsible for
themselves and for other people and also
to point out that
that you have a moral responsibility to
do so
for yourself just as you do for others
and i i think that that message has been
very
helpful to people at least that's what
they've told me the i and it's
predicated that the rule is predicated
on the old judeo-christian idea the
oldest idea in some sense that
you know that there's a relationship
between
logos which is truthful speech and
communication and bringing things into
being from chaotic potential that's the
idea that's put forward in genesis and
also the idea that men and women alike
are made in the image of god which
suggests that like god
we have the capability of
affecting potential affecting the
possible future and turning it into the
actual present and that we do that at
least in part as a consequence of our
ethical choices
treat yourself like you matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about
think about how you talk to other people
you know think about if you're watching
this video if you're a fan of this
channel you are probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even heck even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror
and you're just telling yourself all the
reasons why you can't do something that
voice inside your own head sucks right
telling yourself that you can't make it
that someone like you is never going to
do it we don't treat ourselves with
the same level of compassion empathy
that we have
for other people
you wouldn't talk to your worst enemy
the way that you talk to yourself
and that's a big problem i think that
needs to shift it needs to change
because as long as you keep
talking to yourself
like you're a piece of garbage
then you're never going to accomplish
anything great
we have to start to shift it
i
had a whole bunch of issues in how i
talk to myself
i used to
say well i'm too shy i'm too introvert
i'm nobody's going to want to hear my
story my message doesn't matter who am i
to go off and do this i
have to have a huge
ego even i'm sitting here filming in a
parking lot like i would i would never
do this only only people with
giant egos and
loud mouths would ever do that right i'm
still working to unwind
all of that
but the more you can catch it
and the more you can shift it
it allows you to go off and do great
things not just for yourself but for
other people because if you fast forward
if the way you've been talking to
yourself for the past
couple years continues to be the way
that you talk to yourself for the rest
of your life
nothing changes
so how do we shift how do we get to a
point where hey we're actually saying
better things about ourselves
number one is you have to catch the
voice you know what is the negative
voice what are you saying to yourself
because a lot of it are just
it's not intentional
you know it's these automatic thoughts
it's the subconscious thoughts you come
up with an idea of what you can do and
immediately you shut yourself down
without even noticing it just it's a
default nature instantly boom no i can't
do that no you suck you can't do that
so what are the negative thoughts that
are coming up in your mind and just
trying to catch it
number two is whatever you want to have
more of you need to create that in your
life you need to create the habits and
routines to have more of it in your life
so for me i i want more belief right and
i go through this whole process of how
to figure out your most important core
value or your one word you can pick up
your one word or build the serve it'll
walk you through it
what do you need more of in your life
i need more belief and as much as i'm
trying to spread that to the world with
the videos and everything i make i also
need more of it myself i need more
belief for myself and so what helps me
believe in myself well i try to design a
life and an environment to help bring
that out more so
everything from
the outfit that i wear you know i tell
myself i'm a superhero going to work
this is my believe uniform just like
batman puts on his costume
from what my office looks like and the
pictures on my wall i've got my parents
on my wall and
looking at them reminds me of the
message that my mom would always give me
that
advocacy really carmichael i could do
anything i believe that i can
the videos that i make the the main
channel the top 10 channel this channel
all the content that i make is designed
to help me believe in myself more
that's what helps me come alive
service you know thinking about
how what i'm going to do will have an
impact on somebody else besides me
helps me have the courage to go off and
chase down the goals that i have for
myself so
what is it that makes you come alive
what do you need more of it in your life
because you're probably not getting
enough of it
right the thing that you need more in
your life you're not you're not getting
enough of it right now that's why
that
negative voice is so powerful and
default
so think about the people who you're
hanging around and the media you're
consuming all of it you're not getting
enough of the thing that you need so how
do you get more of that thing and
engineer it design it so that it's part
of your daily calendar that's not
randomly happening in your life but it's
with intent
must happen every day
so number one is catching that voice
what is that voice number two is
designing that environment and the
habits and the routines for yourself so
that you're around it constantly you're
changing our environment to be around
the thing that you know that you want to
be
and then number three is
empower people to pull you out of the
matrix you know empower people to call
you out empower people to give you
feedback
some of my favorite ways to do it
uh whenever i'm going to an event or
whatever i'm talking to somebody i
respect
and i need some help input guidance
feedback i'll say tell me why i suck
tell me why i suck at this thing why do
i suck at this like how do i get better
and when i do that is because they give
me their honest feedback you know when
when you just ask for feedback people
will be afraid of hurting your feelings
and you won't get the full info so i say
tell me why i suck and i say well you
don't suck but
here's what you need to fix
i empower the people around me that if i
say scary difficult or hard
then i have to go up and do the thing
just because i said scary difficult to
heart i don't want to be the person who
plays small
so my son particularly loves this one
right it's like dad you did it you said
scary ah shoot okay now i have to go off
and do it what are your trigger words
what are the things that
make you stay small and then
empower the people around you to call
you out on it
so that
when you don't catch it because you
won't catch it most of the time
you won't catch it
but when you can't catch it and somebody
else can
not being defensive
and not
uh
putting our guard up and realizing that
hey this behavior is keeping me stuck
empowering the people around you to give
you the feedback to pull you out of the
matrix so you can start turning what's
subconscious to conscious
if you feel like
you're a little bit stuck if you feel
like
you know you want to do more and you're
capable of more and you want to serve
more and help more
and you know that you've got this voice
inside you that's keeping you there
and you're struggling with how do i get
it
from subconscious and automatic negative
to subconscious and automatic positive
everything starts to change
you have to treat yourself like you
matter
just imagine that you were actually your
own best friend
just imagine that you came to you with
the problems that you're facing what
would you tell yourself
it's probably going to be something
loving something encouraging something
powerful something positive not the
words that you're actually using to talk
to yourself
this doesn't change in a day you know
doesn't change in an instant
it's a process
but if every day
day by day you can slowly start to
believe in yourself more empower
yourself more
talk yourself in a better way
you're going to create
a much better life for yourself
and then you can pay it forward and help
others
because no matter what words you say
no matter how much you tell people to be
positive again you're here watching this
you are the most positive person you're
in your family you're pouring into other
people no matter how much
words you
use what they'll be inspired by most is
your action
no matter how much you say
hey love yourself make this happen i
believe in you if they see you not
believing in yourself
not taking the action you need to take
they'll never be inspired to do it
themselves either
they'll be most inspired by the actions
that you take
when you're afraid and you doubt
yourself too it's time to make a change
let's make that change today
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's it's a fairly it's a
fairly limited attempt first of all
we're not going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or other you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do
now some of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it
and see what happens and what'll happen
is your vision will clear a little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you could
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear
and final picture of what constitutes
the truth
and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start make
a damn schedule and stick to it okay so
what's the rule with the schedule
it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i have to do this then i have to do this
then i have to do this you know and then
i just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that i have
to do it's like wrong
set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that than at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well i've got these
responsibilities i have to schedule the
damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who is working for you it's like okay
you got to work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
percent the next week or 50 and a half
percent for god's sake or because
you're you're going to hit that position
where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward
and so
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness plan a life you'd
like to have and and you do that partly
by
referring to social norms that's more or
less rescuing your father from the belly
of the whale but the way other way you
do that is by having a little
conversation with yourself about
as if you don't really know who you are
because you know what you're like you
won't do what you're told you won't do
what you tell yourself to do you must
have noticed that it's like you're a bad
employee and a worse boss and both of
those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but
but you know what my point is is that
you have to understand that you're not
your own servant so to speak you're
someone that you have to negotiate with
and that's and you're someone that you
want to present the opportunity of
having a good life to and that's hard
for people because they don't like
themselves very much
so you know they're always like cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and it's like god it's
so boring and such a pathetic way of
spending your time you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a of being
that has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is that
well two as far as i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well
you know there are remarkable people who
come into the world from time to time
and there are people who do find out
over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something i mean you can think
about this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
uh watching things on youtube that not
only do you not want to watch that you
don't even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be
who knows how much more efficient 10
times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are are our major
causes of suffering and the failure of
individuals to adopt the responsibility
that they know they should adopt take a
bit of a look at yourself and think
about what's not so good that you could
improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this stack
of paper there you know and you haven't
looked at that damn stack for like a
month and you know that you should be
and you're
bothering yourself at night because
you're avoiding that it's like maybe
think i've avoided that stack of paper
completely for one month i'm quite a
coward when it comes to whatever snakes
might be hidden in that stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like
i glanced through it for
15 seconds
see if i can do that it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper
you know it could easily be you've been
avoiding it you're obviously afraid of
it and so the situation could be that
dismal and dire
and you might think well geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the
strength of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of and so that's a form
of humility too it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction and then the
question is are you big enough to take
those small steps you know are you
capable of
grappling with the fact that you're
fundamentally flawed to the point where
you have to break things down into
almost childlike steps in order to
manage them an answer to that is yeah
you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out generally
you get better at it and you can take on
larger and larger challenges adopt the
mode of
authentic being
and that is something like
refusing to participate in
the lie in deception in the lie to
orient your speech as much as you can
towards the truth
and to take responsibility for your own
life and perhaps also for the lives of
other people and there's something about
that that's
meaningful and responsible and noble but
also serves to mitigate the very
suffering that produces
say the nihilism or the flea into the
arms of flea or or the or the escape
into the arms of totalitarians to begin
with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability i started
to pay very careful attention to what i
was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas
and there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea you don't really
believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts so then i had a this
weird conundrum is like well which of
these two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as a coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen but you have to be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well
and it might be so embarrassing that you
can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
fathom that that's actually who you are
but you know
jung described the full
the archetypal figure of the trickster
and the fool as the precursor to the
savior to the redeemer and that's
unbelievable bit of wisdom because
what you meant was that
to put yourself together which is to
follow the path of redemption
to follow the redeemer
if the redeemer is a type of personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
or manifest
then this first step towards that is to
allow yourself to be a fool
right
it's because
you you don't know what you're doing
you have to admit that and there's going
to be a loss of ego or destruction of
ego arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that but you need the loss
of that arrogant ego because it's
precisely what's interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process mythologically
speaking that stops moral progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice what you're like so that
you could change properly you don't want
to sacrifice that part of yourself it's
probably associated with some delusion
that helps you maintain
in
what you say a positive although very
fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort the best thing
you can do is teach people to write
because there's no difference between
that and thinking and one of the things
that just blows me away about
universities is that
no one ever tells students why they
should write something it's like well
you have to do this assignment
well why are you writing well you need
the grade it's like no
you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly
nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
and i can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you can
possibly provide someone with and i mean
i know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life i mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and not in a malevolent way it's like if
you're gonna make your point and they're
gonna make their point you better have
your points
organized because otherwise you're gonna
look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not gonna get anywhere
and if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation if
you can speak to people if you can lay
out a proposal god people give you money
they give you opportunities you have
influence one of the things i've been
talking to my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying um
messages let's say or themes is a better
way of thinking about it
you know if you start with the
presumption
that there's a baseline of suffering in
life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and and they have the reasons
but you need something to put
up against that and what you put up
against that is meaning meaning is
actually the instinct that helps you
guide yourself through that catastrophe
and most of that meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've justified you've
justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
how you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or yeah or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that
and so
if you think about the times when you're
at peace with yourself with regards to
how you're conducting yourself in the
world it's almost always conditions
under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt i think that you can
experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to
but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that if you
concentrate solely on your career
you can get a long way in your career
and i would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially do
that that's all they do they work like
70 80 hours a week they go flat out on
their career they're staking everything
on the small probability of exceptional
status in a narrow domain but it's hard
on them they don't have a life it's very
difficult for them to have a family they
don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very one
dimensional now it may be that that unit
dimensionality is the price you have to
pay to be exceptional at one thing right
because if you're going to be something
like a genius level mathematician and
you want to do that for or a scientist
say it's like you're in your lab you're
in your lab all the time you're working
70 hours a week or 80 hours a week
you're smart you're dedicated you're
uni-dimensional and that's how you get
to beat all the other people who are
doing that it's the only way
but the problem is you don't get a life
now if you love being a scientist and
you have that kind of
focus of mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're going to
pay for it but fine more power to you
but
but
it's a
it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and i
would say most often if you're speaking
about having a healthy life that isn't
what you do
you spread yourself out more so you know
you have a family you have some things
that you do outside of work that are
meaningful to you and useful
you you have a network of friends
um well that those three things alone
are
four things alone or plenty to keep you
well oriented and then if one of those
things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now
the price you pay for that is the more
you strive to optimize that balance the
less likely you are to be fantastically
successful at any single one of them but
you might have a very you know if you
can consider your life as a whole
that might be a winning strategy if
you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless
you're like a rabbit
rabbit isn't virtuous
it's just
just can't do anything except get eaten
it's not virtuous
if you're a monster and you don't
act monstrously
then you're virtuous but you also have
to be a monster well you see this all
the time harry potter is like that too
it's like he's he's flawed he's hurt
he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man he breaks rules all the time
all the time he's not obedient at all
but you know he has a good reason for
breaking the rules and it if he couldn't
break the rules him and his little
clique of rule-breaking you know
troublemakers if they didn't break the
rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal
so it's very peculiar but it's very very
it's a very very very very common
mythological notion you know the hero
has to be
the hero has to be a monster
but a controlled monster batman is like
that you know i mean it's it's
everywhere it's it's the story you
always hear when i was 25 or so i
probably weighed about 138 pounds i
smoked like pack cigarettes day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot i
started when i was 14 and you know um
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i
i quit smoking oh that took a long time
because i eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done i don't
regret that i had a fine time when i was
a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined and i
had to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since i
was
probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that
got to the point around 25 when i was in
graduate school trying to get my phds
doing all my research like i published
15 papers by the time i graduated with
my phd which was by i think by a fairly
large measure the most papers that any
un graduate student at that time had
ever published at mcgill i think that's
right might have been twice as many or
maybe twice as many maybe even three
times as many and at the same time i
wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my what what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
i had to stop that's a sacrifice i had
to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
overprotected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind i
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the great father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40.
so then you take people out you say well
what are you afraid of rank it from one
to ten
so ten is
make a list of ten things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number ten
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
ten times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned and then you move a little
closer and then you move a little closer
and then you move a little closer and
finally you're back in what's no longer
the elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that and then
you're met much more
together much more confident and that's
often one of the things that often
happens in situations like that i've
seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up to people around them in a
way they never did before if you
concentrate solely on your career
you can get a long way in your career
and i would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially do
that that's all they do they work like
70 80 hours a week they go flat out on
their career they're staking everything
on the small probability of exceptional
status in a narrow domain but it's it's
hard on them they don't have a life it's
very difficult for them to have a family
they don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very
one-dimensional now it may be that that
unidimensionality is the price you have
to pay to be exceptional at one thing
right because if you're going to be
something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for or a scientist say it's like you're
in your lab you're in your lab all the
time you're working 70 hours a week or
80 hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated you're uni-dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a scientist
and you have that kind of
focus of mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're going to
pay for it but fine more power to you
but
but
it's a
it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and i
would say most
often if you're speaking about having a
healthy life that isn't what you do
you spread yourself out more so you know
you have a family you have some things
that you do outside of work that are
meaningful to you and useful
you you have a network of friends
um well that those three things alone
are
four things alone or plenty to keep you
well oriented and then if one of those
things collapses
you know everything doesn't go
now the the price you pay for that is
the more you strive to optimize that
balance the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them but you might have a very
you know if you can consider your life
as a whole
that might be a winning strategy i had a
plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and i
was going to test the joints they're
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and i said i told him i
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and i thought yeah that's
okay how about if i test them so i went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to and
like half an hour later i had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable uh forthright productive way
of making a living and there is a hell
of a lot of difference between a working
man who knows what he's doing and one
who doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of egalitarian
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one go trying another
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top you know flap about
uselessly and whine about your life it's
not helpful it'll just make you
miserable you're not reliable to anyone
you can't help out in a crisis it's like
so you tell young people and this is
another message for conservatives like i
don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for god's sake be an honest
person and work and get to the top of
whatever it is that you want to get to
the top of you know and and and
and that stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard a month
ago month and a half used to teach there
and i talked to a bunch of students you
know when i told them
it's not easy to get into harvard you
know like you're a valedictorian if
you're at harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am i saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so i told them what i just told you
it's like here you are at harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out we're built for struggle us human
beings
you're not after
the bubbles of bliss that dostoevsky
described in in notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have
also people that have extracted
unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures
and so and i'm not saying that in a
naive way i know perfectly well what
happens to people you know you're doing
fine in life and then you get cancer and
then six months later you're dead and
all the heroism in the world isn't going
to save you at that point but that's not
the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do it isn't merely that
your fate depends on whether or not you
get your act together and to what degree
you decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about nine billion by the way and
then it'll decline rapidly but seven
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust mote
among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do
they're like dropping a stone in a pond
the ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit
or even more importantly if it's a light
if it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century
this the baboon here who's supposed to
be basically just a fool when the story
was first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just the
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too you don't tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail
you say here's something worth going
after here's a step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone
you're expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay i need to set a
goal but i need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it and then you go then
you've got it perfectly because it's not
so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well i could do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why being a victim yeah which
isn't helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem but there are
certainly proper ways of dealing with it
if you configure your life
so that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good
then the things that you need to
to survive
and to thrive on a day-to-day basis
will deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because it what
it basically says is if you dare to do
the most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a kierkegaardian
leap of faith there's no way you're
going to find out whether or not that's
true unless you do it so no one no one
can tell you either because
just because it works for someone else i
mean that's interesting and all that but
it's no proof that it'll work for you
you have to be all in in this game there
is no more effective way of operating in
the world than to conceptualize the
highest good that you can and then
strive to attain it there's no
more practical pathway
to the kind of success that you could
have if you actually knew what success
was the world shifts itself
around your aim
because you're you're a creature that
has a name you have to have a name in
order to do something you're an aiming
creature you look at a point and you
move towards it it's built right into
you
and so you have a name well let's say
your aim is the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you it organizes all of your
perceptions it organizes what you see
and you don't see it organizes your
emotions and your motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly then you stay on the pathway
towards that ape and you can concentrate
on the on the on the day and so that way
you get to have your cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's
that makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize well that's the very
definition of the meaning that would
sustain you in your life you have to
negotiate until you come to the best
solution that can be negotiated which
isn't necessarily a perfect solution but
it might be the best one that can be
done and then you have to stick with it
until the next negotiation and
if you get upset during the negotiations
which you likely will because these are
difficult topics how to divide up
responsibilities in the house and people
get mad because they feel they've been
taken advantage of or aren't being
listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got the balance
between making peace and speaking the
truth right if the conversation
continues and it can be emotional and
will be and can be difficult because
important things have to be dealt with
but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
gonna agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision before you can be a painter who
can paint what's beyond mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and
and even to some degree whatever
creativity you have is going to have to
be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is their places of
guidance and and they're places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines right i mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of that that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it and so then
the question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction this is
nietzsche's commentary on the catholic
church he's a great admirer of the
catholic church despite the fact that he
was also a radical
critic
critic of christianity he said the cat
see the thing about the catholic church
is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline
and once that discipline was established
then the disciplined mind could explode
in every direction which is precisely
what happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that when you're a
teenager and a young adult you have to
sacrifice everything you could have been
as a child to be the one thing that
you're aiming at but then that opens up
and and the universities are part and
parcel of that process and you need the
guidance because
the
the the library is too large to wander
through it unaided you'll discover a
little bit more about your potential as
you discover who you are especially the
darker parts of yourself
because then you discover your potential
for mayhem there's some real utility in
that
you know a discovery that you're
dangerous it's such a useful discovery
it's actually something that strengthens
you because the first thing
that a realization like that can in fact
produce is
the ambition to incorporate that danger
into a higher order personality that
dangerousness into a higher order
personality and that can make you
implacable
i can make you someone who can say no
when you need to say no
you know that can make you someone who
won't avoid necessary conflict and so
that's
unbelievably useful
if you want another amazing jordan
peterson video check it out right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there let's say you want to fix up your
house
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up which is a very
common dream metaphor well the first
thing you want to do is go look around
and see what needs to be fixed